I don't worry about the sin of the world
as a scientist I I have no I don't worry
about the state of war I only worry
about scientific questions for example
my current work shows that on the
average level of intelligence and and in
all wasn't populations is going down
that worries some of my colleagues
intelligence research the fact that as
populations the average intelligence is
going down doubt doesn't worry me I
don't worry about societal trends I only
worry about scientific questions and
solutions so what keeps me up a night is
is solving scientific problems I don't
solve society's problems I don't care
about society's problems
assoc like I said defective intelligence
on fertility behavior all my research
right now involves arm what intelligent
people value and prefer and part of what
intelligent people value prefer is not
having children or having fewer children
than less intelligent people
um this work hasn't been published yet
but probably more intelligent people
more likely to be homosexual because
once again it is unnatural to be
homosexual in the sense that all
biological beings are designed to be
heterosexual designed for heterosexual
reproduction so in that limited sense it
is unnatural to be exclusively
homosexual and for that reason probably
more intelligent people are more likely
to be homosexual the less intelligent
people to pick any unnatural things that
we're not designed for one children
people more likely to do it